- [Narrator] In the whacky
world of infomercials
there is one man that
is the most famous face
in the industry.
- It's OxiClean.
It gets the tough stains out.
Kaboom!
This is the Turbo Scrub.
The rechargeable Cordless Power Scrubber.
Then of course, there's the
incredible Sticky Buddy.
It's slippy when it's wet,
and it's sticky when it's dry.
Hi, Anthony Sullivan here,
for the Sticky Buddy.
I am a pitchman by trade.
Look at that.
It cuts right through
this soft skin tomato.
I'm so excited, I'm getting out of breath.
A pitchman just excels at being able
to sell certain products.
Where is the OxiClean shirt?
This is the magic shirt.
It's like putting on Superman's cape.
OxiClean gets the tough stains out.
Is there anything in my teeth?
- Looks good.
- I started off selling when
I was 22 at a street market
in England, and one day,
I turned on the television
and I saw my first infomercial,
and a lightbulb went off
in my head. And I thought, "I
need to get in front of
"the TV camera and get off the street."
- [Camera Man] And put it down.
- You missed a spot.
Some of the products that
we've sold over the years are
the Swivel Sweeper, the Turbo
Scrub, the Sticky Buddy,
OxiClean, Orange Glo, this
Hurricane Spin Mop, Clever Cam.
The list is endless.
It has quad brush technology.
Forwards, backwards, or side
to side, and the worst part is
we didn't charge the batteries.
I think one of the most common
questions I ever get asked
is does it really work
as good as it works?
Which I think is one of
the reasons why people
are attracted to "As Seen
on TV", 'cause you're like,
"You gotta see this product.
Do you see what it does?
It does everything".
Clean the toilet, or clean your car.
It'll clean your washing machine.
It'll clean your floors.
It'll clean this, clean that.
I love it when I can do a "Wow
demo" that people sit at home
and go, "Oh my God.
"Look at that. Really works".
It's the power of air.
It's been a struggle.
I haven't had the wind
behind me the whole way.
But, um, it's been an amazing journey
and I continue to really,
really enjoy what I do.
I'm never doing that again.